[Music]
the fosters alert hurricane Irma is
headed toward Florida and is now
expected to turn back into a category 5
hurricane before it slams into the
Sunshine State joining us now is Florida
Attorney General Pam Bondi Pam we're
both conservatives we've seen
devastation when things aren't handled
right locally in the case of Katrina but
between Texas and and I've got to give
props to you and the governor and state
and local officials and and the White
House and FEMA everybody seems to be
pre-positioned prepared the governor has
been telling people for days now to
evacuate you have been working with
other states to get gas necessary for
the people to to evacuate also food and
supplies have been brought in
expeditiously tell us what's going on
down there how prepared is the state
Sean you know it's up to God it's in
God's hands now but I'll tell you what
we could not be more prepared as the
state Governor Scott has been everywhere
constantly and thank goodness people are
listening to him Home Depot last week
they sold over 335 thousand sheets of
lumber so that should tell you that
people are listening they're boarding up
their houses I set in president Trump's
office earlier in the week and I mean he
cares he truly cares about our state
scott pruett let us do blended gas he he
led up on some of the regulations now
for us for 20 days so we can drive the
prices of fuel down for our state I
cannot thank FEMA enough state local and
federal government we're seeing at work
it's working well in Florida you know
and there are so many good corporations
so many so much good out there but of
course we're always going to have the
bad ones my job unfortunately is to have
to deal with a lot of the báb we've
received over 7700 complaints Shawn just
since the emergency orders been issued
on prime couching I spoke to it I heard
this earlier today now we've got to give
credit where credit is due I know the
CEO of Home Depot and and he called you
early in the week is that how can I go
what can we do JetBlue was giving
flights out of Florida for 99 dollars
and then other airlines to their credit
followed suit as well right
but you said 7700 they were selling like
cases of water that would normally go
for three four or five bucks for like
thirty and forty and you have to crack
down on them eventually right
III do and I will let me tell you if you
are gouging in my state I'm coming after
you and I will be on the show with you
naming these businesses and I hope
Floridians never walk in those stores
again the JetBlue American United Delta
they've all been incredible Amazon's
been working so well with us Home Depot
called me so what do you need and they
are delivering trucks they were as long
as they could
you know what pretty much everyone has
been amazing for the most part we say of
course we've had some bad actors and we
always will people please call my
price-gouging hotline one eight six six
nine no scams we won't help you yet why
you did have those it really is amazing
I mean times like this you see people
come together we saw it in Texas we're
seeing it now in Florida the warnings
have now been going out for days and
days if your coastal if you're in
southern Florida get out of the way
particular lives protect your families
but it is nice to see these companies
these corporations and the government
you know use the information satellite
technology meteorology that information
to protect people's lives so a lot of
good so far that we've seen this week
and the coordination federal state local
officials seems to be superb at this
point do you feel everything is
pre-positioned coming in after the storm
to help all these Floridians out that
are going to need that help oh I do I do
in the federal government's been amazing
Governor Scott again everything
everything we're pre-positioned that
again it's in God's hands right now
people have to listen people still can
leave it's not too late to leave if you
haven't yet important to know you still
have time please leave your possessions
can be replaced your family members your
pets cannot leave with your medications
leave with your prescriptions get out of
here it's not too late the highways are
open if you have to sit in traffic it's
still you're plenty of time to get out
get out if you're going to stay board up
your house and keep plenty of supplies
and but you know Shawn if you're gouging
in Florida we're going to come after you
this is not the time to be taking taken
advantage of our fellow Florida for you
Pam and and listen our thoughts and
prayers are with all our friends or any
in Florida this is a big one one of the
other great stories I heard and you told
me earlier that the airlines were also
allowing people to bring their pets for
free sure I could never leave my pets
behind I know you have a big dog so you
know my st. bernard de i they've been
great they've waived change all three of
hounds I've never seen him talk about
big I don't like it that they would take
up all of JetBlue itself it's the
biggest dog I've ever seen
all right pay thank you for what you're
doing it is you and the governor and all
the people of Florida